salve no un'altra ascensore perfetto una
mina non l'avevo mica capita sta cosa
allora devo riuscire a superarlo senza
toccarla forse magari se no no no
sbaglio di nuovo ficano
pronto pizza si una quattro formaggi è
una margherita si ok perfetto quindi
posso correre però non so dove cazzo
andare questa è la cosa brutta non
vorrei trovarmi lo dietro poi
la seconda più richiesta invece è stato
fa vj cioè molti di voi mi hanno chiesto
di materializzare me stesso però ragazze
io scrivo dei nomi veri lui non può
materializzare sì sì sì sì
no non c'è niente non c'è niente
lei there be light oddio non ci credo ma
funzionato davvero spero che non sia
fufi ho sentito il rumore
ho sentito un rumore non è piaciuto ho
sentito il rumore che non mi è piaciuto
ma penso che sia bambino che corre nudo
va beh porca [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
raga mi è venuta un'idea prova a fare
tipo limbo mi abbasso qua ci vuole la
musichetta adatta cazzo a nixon thing ok
che cazzo dove di questo dove di questo
non lo puoi prendere questo addio
guardate la testa del verde
guarda senza aiutami salvare mio amico
ma non uccidere nessuno questo è senza
dubbio un lavoro per jack sparrow però
jack sparso feste jack sparso apre i
cassetti fantastico tipo come se fosse
casa mia tra veramente dov'è la nutella
per verificare se il paziente
effettivamente è conscio bisogna provare
a mandarlo a quel paese
se vedete che il paziente non risponde a
questa provocazione molto probabilmente
è ancora privo di coscienza e quindi si
può passare alla fase numero 2 regalo lo
scopo di harry potter
[Musica]
l'anzhi ogni volta che apro le porte
raga perché devo aprirle così
ok andiamo avanti porca [ __ ] porcata
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no se ok poi cos'è il governo stai
calmissimo oddio oddio oddio questo odio
mi violenta ma che cazzo fa
by se l'inter va già in a ok
vai col bambino madonna che mira che
mira a shock e molto delicatamente molto
porca [ __ ]
l'ultima volta mi stava quasi stuprando
adesso se n'è andato non vedo cazzo ok
hyon ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ciao pif ciò
che mi fa piacere rivederti ok fa vj da
sono stato bene cosa sta succedendo è
una volta arrivati a questo punto come
sempre bisogna rimuovere il cuore
sperando che si tolga madonna come file
avere un incidente sulla barca cazzo sei
donne ottobre a freddie mercury
perché c'è freddie mercury ok
ce la fa ce la faccio merda staccavo
delle palle che mi no no no no no no no
no no no no no cazzo merda no non
applica aprirà una lietissima porta
andiamo contro l ultima stanza ragazzo
fantastico ma che cazzo è successo
trampolino a molle
non lo so come cazzo lo volevi sono ma è
ovvio che cazzo è successo
mio zio
[Musica]
questa digis madness madness days e
sport assicuriamoci di inserire il cuore
poi se ne ha due a meno se se ne rompe
uno l'altro di scorta quindi magari due
cuori du corps is meglio che one
quindi no no no no non ci credo dove
notte 23 qua
addio quarti sono no no no no finocchi
tutte ma io vado direttamente dagli
altri non è dio
oddio che cazzo è il marrone è morto è
saltato tipo forse cosa è successo sono
l'ultimo no no no no ci siamo ragazzi
siamo non vanno non vorrei mai andare
gli assi cristo no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no merda a me dopo
indietro ma indietro indietro corri
maledetto idiota con ricordi
[Musica]
via via via via via via via via via via
via via con via cazzo cazzo cosa sta
facendo
porca [ __ ] no no no no no no no sono
venuto aiuto allora è ovvio
mio zio santissimo ma sto cazzo di
trampolino e massimo
mappa per farvi j buy back door riesce a
raggiungere il traguardo
me lo chiedi anche ma scherzi c'è il
traguardo traguardo il mio secondo nome
ok bene facciamo il mio terzo
cazzo mi sa che nell'altra stanza o che
devo muovermi dovere devo muovere devo
muovere il culo
vabbè nel caso vi cade il martello
all'interno del vostro paziente
ricordatevi di nasconderlo con qualche
oggetto in modo che il paziente non si
accorga di quello che è successo
ok sta arrivando da qualche parte non so
dove ma sta arrivando ma ce la sto
facendo già sto facendo
sì posso fare antonelli dov'è e li
stronzo dai dai dai dai dai dai 6
ma
es
i fakti slot she's not stronza one
chance mi mi attira ragazzi qua chance
to kill the backs ok dai beach
io non ho mai del paese fu c'è poi c'è
di nuovo questo poi c'è di nuovo il cavo
di nuovo il foglio c'è di nuovo la luce
poi c'e di nuovo questo poi c'è di nuovo
il cavo poi c'è stat roja
oddio è morto guardatelo
[Musica]
ho imparato il fossero da come mossa
c'è un bello fu che doveva dove vai qui
dove vai
hanno usato qualcosa ha pensato una
merda no veramente lui che la lascia la
merda
magari poi la pesto io no dove stai
andando perché allora no non andare lì
fu fino ad andare lì fu fin o nanda ok
fuori j versus tentacolo brutto stronzo
i capelli sono più lunghi 3d di
sorprendermi ok sculaccia il mio
maledetto per l'appunto fallo voglio
andare per mare tsunami cos'è no no io
cosa fai traditore di merda mi stuprano
mi scoprono sull'abisso visto allora ha
permesso c'è qualcuno o salverebbe la
giornata vero aspetti un secondo che no
kids che ci fa no non ha spento cazzo
merda devo riuscire a seminarlo al più
presto
e ancora dietro si cazzo sì sì sono
uscito come si esce come si esce di qua
come sia esso di qua
no no per non andare devi iscriverti
bassi cure ok perfetto sono morto ok
sono diventato una pignata e c'è il
prete che vuole vuole qualcosa che ci
libera mii dal male
amen una porca [ __ ]
dove
aiuto
sono stato bravo a dio che violenza ma
perché è basta
ma che è che starò mai male la crisi
chiesa fosse già auguri come da apposito
guarda cosa mi ha fatto passare lurido
stronzo di un cane perfetto c'è anche la
forbice che non avevo notato quindi si
può prendere anche la forbice o cazzo
cazzo non morire bella tutti ragazzi io
sono fa vj spero che il montaggio vi sia
piaciuto da adesso in avanti in base ai
vari eventi che si presenteranno
usciranno tantissimi altri video
speciali
ho tantissimi altri progetti che ho già
in mente di fare comunque volevo
soltanto ringraziarvi per avermi fatto
raggiungere questo traguardo davvero
incredibile siano a quota 10 mila
non mi sarei mai aspettato tutto questo
è sempre un piacere sapere di riuscire a
farvi divertire con i miei video non ho
intenzione di smettere perché adoro
quello che faccio come adoro tutti
quanti voi d'aver ragazzi senza di voi
non sarei qui adesso a dire queste cose
quindi impiego sempre delle ore tutti i
giorni per preparare il video da
pubblicare per il giorno dopo ai vostri
bellissimi commenti che mi lasciate ogni
volta così come mi piace i video sono le
motivazioni che mi bastano e mi spingono
a continuare quello che faccio per voi
quindi ragazzi grazie grazie davvero di
cuore a tutti
in conclusione ragazzi se il video vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e
noi ci vediamo a un prossimo video dai
ragazzi
[Musica]
calcio non pagante un casino
palmi
[Musica]